I would now like to calculate
the potential function for two
other conservative
forces that we
encounter all the
time, spring forces
and gravitational forces.
Will begin with spring forces.
So first off, let's begin with
some type of coordinate system.
Suppose we have a spring.
We have a block.
This is my point x
equilibrium, unstretched
length of the spring.
And now whether we stretch
it or compress it here,
I'll stretch it.
I'll introduce a
coordinate function x.
Union vector i, and
my spring force, f,
is -kxi, where x can be
positive for a stretch spring,
force is in the negative
i-hat direction.
When x is negative,
negative times negative,
means the spring force is in the
positive i-hat direction when
it's compressed.
So this is a force
that's a restoring force,
always back to equilibrium.
This is an example of
a conservative force.
And now let's calculate the
change in potential energy.
And then introduce a
zero reference point
and get a potential
function for this force.
So the first calculation
is straightforward.
So, if we took our
displacement to be dx i-hat.
And we take the
dot product of fds,
we get dx i-hat dot
i-hat is 1, times dx.
And that's just the x component
of the force displacement.
And minus sign because the x
component of the force is -kx.
And so now, if we were
to start our system,
so, again, for
our initial state,
let's say that the block from
the unstretched position,
is stretched xi.
And our final state, whether
it's stretched or compressed,
it won't matter, but we'll just
stretch it out a little bit
more to x-final.
So now let's
calculate the change
in potential energy between our
initial and our final states.
Now, recall there's
a minus sign,
because it's -w conservative.
That's minus the integral
x-initial to x-final of -kxdx.
We have 2 minus signs.
That's our integration
variable, if you
want to see all the detail.
And when you simply
integrate x-prime dx-prime,
you get x-prime squared over 2.
And so the change in potential
energy between these two states
is 1/2 kx-final squared,
minus 1/2 kx-initial squared.
And that's physically meaningful
if I take my system initially.
And the system ends
up in the final state.
Then what I'm calculating
is minus the work
done by the spring
force on the block
as it goes from the initial
state to the final state.
I'm not talking about the
work that an external agent
does in stretching
or compressing it.
This is explicitly the
work done by the spring
force on the block as it
goes from the initial state
to the final state.
I introduced the minus
sign in our definition
of potential energy.
And so this quantity
represents the negative
of the work done
by the spring force
as a system goes from the
initial to the final states.
Now, you may have
already thought about it,
but the reference point
that we're going to use
is x equals zero.
The unstretched
length of the spring.
And our reference potential
at that point will be zero.
So our reference point is
actually the zero-point
for the potential.
And then our arbitrary
state, we can call this
the referent state, if you like.
That's probably better
than the reference point.
Our arbitrary state will
be at some arbitrary
stretch or compress.
And our potential
energy function,
at that reference, minus
the potential energy
at the arbitrary state,
minus the reference state.
Well, if we set xi equal
to 0 and x-final equal
to x, as we have
in this expression,
we simply get 1/2 kx squared.
So the potential energy function
equals our reference potential,
plus 1/2 kx squared.
And we have defined that our
reference potential to be zero,
it could have been anything.
But we're making it 0 so that
we get a nice function, 1/2 kx
square.
And again, it's always
worthwhile to plot
that function.
It's a nice parabola.
U of x, x.
And you can see down here,
that's our reference point.